no
e la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono fa vj tantissimo allora
allora partiamo in modo semplice
parimenti ragazzi la disney
c'è un braccio solo col quale sto
tenendo il telefono quindi con l'altro
ho un po di difficoltà la disney mentre
c'è questo sottofondo musicale mio papà
crediti a mio papà pj vevo iscrivetevi
favola disney mi ha inviato per la
promozione del film b b 8 gli sarebbe il
droide di star wars la versione droide
che ti gioia dovrebbe essere tipo
animale domestico
c'è una roba che a raffica ta pazzesca e
hanno anche inviato le googlecar board
che sarebbero queste qui che veramente
una è una sorta di oculus rift fatto di
cartone una cosa bellissima star wars ma
forse questo si era capito teoria se
tutti momenti tipo così se dovrei vedere
la realtà virtuale di star wars soulor
che ci dove infilare il telefono con il
quale sto riprendendo però ci prova uno
stormtrooper un vero guerriero 30
ragazzi sta usando l'applicazione di
star wars con i google car board in
questo momento si trova nel mondo dei
geni vero va p mio padre che sta
suonando sempre lievo sto sfruttando e
tipo ai matrimoni la cosa più [ __ ] e che
essendo tutto di a tema star wars io e
trattano conoscendolo più swift non
pensavo potesse esserci una realtà
virtuale a mo di cartone gru che sia
ragazzi passiamo al pezzo clou della
della situation perché penso che
preferisco io che lui nel caso non si
fosse capito dalla magnificenza della
realtà virtuale che ho provato prima
sono andato a prendermi i pupazzi a tema
star wars che vi faccio vedere muovere
solo droide viene un pò un casino perché
poi alla fine che cosa vi faccio fare
quando a prender le banane pensavo di
fare un percorso a ostacoli solo che è
un po un casino per sempre per il fatto
che non è che posso mettere le fiamme in
giro perché sono libero cial droid e mi
sono andata a prendere i pupazzetti
questi di star wars che che io io a
parte faccio la collezione delle
scadenze a casa su un pieno e fino
allora ci avevo solo quella di ci becca
che ciò a casa mia a milano e ho preso
queste così da
per creare una sorta di percorso ad
ostacoli l'unico problema è che mancano
yoda il two becca che sono i miei amori
per questo lo sapevate già avute
cult e figo yoda stiamo per assistere e
anni non ha la patente però non so se
serve una patente per guidare android
va bene no ma come fa un aspetto ferma
la madonna ha detto tutto della musica
si va bene mi sembra l'esagerazione
voglio come andare drive c'è trento
ragazzi sull'applicazione c'è scritto
questa applicazione b b 8 e nei poemi
ball droid incontra b b 8 il vostro
molto proprio cosa vuol dire apre nei
ball droide aspro meccanico c'è questi
hanno tradotto altro meccanico la molto
proprio cosa vuol dire ai a testate moto
il ghiaccio la torta
vuoi un milione di dollari
no non li guardo
si no
sei fatta bellissimo gran cosa ma voi
ragazzi in teoria il percorso che
tenteremo di fare sarà tipo questo
allora il robot parte da divano il
percorso dovrebbe essere questo tutto il
divano poi c'è questa cosa che non
passerò mai ci sono tutti gli ostacoli
da superare dopodiché c'è la discesa di
libri dopo la discesa di libri cela lo
slalom tra le scatole e voi dovrebbe
arrivare io penso che mi fermerò
esattamente le black jack poi
dai ma perché non ci credo sì va bene va
bene se no la dietro la foglia in realtà
arrivato so che scemo ma quanto mi date
da 1 a 10 c 2 ed è già tanto
e nulla ragazzi questo è stato il mio
cell la è stata la prova di guida
incredibile tanto mio padre ancora di
che suona cielo viene così data ieri
questo video durato due giorni e
suonando la due giorni è il mio droide
in realtà è controllato con lo
smartphone da un'altra persona
comunque sì ragazzi il film andrò a
vederlo con i miei amici ma in realtà
star wars non ha fatto conoscere lui che
non ha una personalità e un robot
sto parlando ma noi non mi ascolta in
realtà sta solo suonando se volete
prenotare i biglietti ragazzi vi lascio
linking descrizione che mi pare che sia
il risveglio della forza punto.it se ciò
azzeccato sta iniziando a sparire
l'alzheimer è un buon segno halloween o
e viene niente ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto il comma 106 video è piaciuto
lo stato argomento è un mi piace anche
la faccia di facebook e come lo trovate
in do description il mio babbo
risalutiamo facciamola chiusa tipo la
perdurava rivale di sarwar
entrata mia madre i pupazzi e va
riguarda decresce mio padre si avvicina
a lui e fa da soda si è scoperto che io
darei una terzo da lui fa le discoteche